it's a huge issue globally and this goes  to where the professor was talking  in terms of American values and and  balancing that with cultural norms and  in different parts of the world we are  highlighting as American government we  are highlighting this issue as often as  we can we're talking about this issue in  forums the secretary brings it up the  statements i have made from the State  Department but there's there are people  on the ground that are actually doing  the hard core work are in fact as you  said the the NGOs I'd I wasn't I don't  know enough about what NGO she was  talking about and the lack of money and  the funds but it is not the majority of  Muslim communities around the world that  uses that mechanism as a punishment tool  that's pretty obvious it's horrifying it  happens in the modern world and we need  to highlight it that's that's the  capacity that's the most we can do at  the moment